hello street talkers and welcome back to
the channel
today we had a really cool conversation
with zach jolst he's a research
scientist from amazon and his specialism
is in graph neural networks and
geometric deep learning which of course
i'm very interested in as well so yeah
we we spoke all about message passing
and a whole bunch of stuff around that
but anyway i hope this video gives you a
bit of a feel for what cool guy zack is
and more importantly how much of a good
educator he is and the reason i'm saying
that is he's gone and created a course
he spent the last six months or so
creating a few courses in fact all
around graph neural networks and you can
sign up i think the current cohort is
nearly full but there's still time for
you to sign up if you do it quickly and
there's a link in the video description
which will give you folks about 50 off
um anyway if you like content like this
please consider hitting the like and
subscribe button
i really love reading your comments as
one of the most fun things for me having
a youtube channel is reading reading the
comments that you folks send in anyway
enjoy the conversation
cheers
so anyway here we are
zach welcome to unplugged hey good to
see you man it's been a while
it has been a while can you can you
introduce yourself to the audience sure
my name's zach jost i
am applied scientist at aws right now i
also have a youtube channel the welcome
ai overlords i've recently been spending
a lot of time building a course on graph
neural networks just kind of finished up
the content creation for that so now i'm
getting back into the world of making
youtube content
amazing and i just watched your recent
interview can you tell us a little bit
about that
the paper was called equivalent subgraph
aggregation networks and it was about
essentially breaking the bottleneck that
gnns currently have that's uh an
artifact of
message passing and we can dig deeper
into that if you want but essentially
whenever you're using a g n what most of
them do is that when you're calculating
a prediction for a node on a graph you
gather the information from its
connected neighborhood
and use that to inform the prediction
and the problem is that
since these things have the symmetry
about
this permutation symmetry so that
there's no natural ordering to the nodes
that you have to use a function that
sort of allows that permutation symmetry
but by doing that by restricting to that
class of functions you end up having
these blind spots so that two
neighborhoods that are actually
different can look the same to this
function and generate the same output
and that gives you a sort of bottleneck
for expressive power
so
they were
[Music]
exploring that idea and then generated a
method that will
break those symmetries that that cause
that bottleneck
and uh then therefore give you more
expressive power
okay there are so many things to unpack
i mean first of all folks everyone must
subscribe to zach's youtube channel so
uh zach is is an insane specialist
especially when it comes to graph neural
networks and as he was just saying he's
put a course together we'll go through
that course and and we'll talk about the
various different things in in a minute
but i suggest you sign up to that course
as well um i feel like zach and i have
been in it since the beginning because
we we created our youtube channel i
think at a similar time so um we've been
on a similar trajectory
maybe we should rewind a little bit to
geometric deep learning in general so um
i spoke with
michael bronstein etau
and they formalized this notion of
geometric deep learning which is a
blueprint
for many of the deep learning
architectures whether it's rnns or cnns
or gnns or transformers and they defined
it a bit like a sandwich
where you have group equivariant
layers
and they are equivariant in respect of a
symmetry transformation and the symmetry
could be translation in time or space or
it could be permutation
uh etcetera etcetera and then you have a
local
um
pooling layer and then you rinse and
repeat that several times and at the end
you have a globally invariant layer
which is usually the mlp
and it's quite interesting that all of
the neural network architectures are
basically instances of that blueprint
yeah
their work is fascinating and uh by
being perfectly honest i struggle to
understand a lot of it you know it's
like it's been a journey for me to try
to build up the base
and then i'll you know read their stuff
it's it's over my head and then i'll
find some nugget of an idea that i
appreciate the uh core of it but i
you know it's like trying to figure out
an elephant with your eyes closed you
know you're like you're starting to feel
a bit of a shape but uh i don't have a
clear picture so then i kind of
disappear for a couple months and read
some other papers and i'll see something
that goes oh that reminds me of that
thing i read in the in bronze scenes
groups work
and then i'll go back and read it and it
makes a little bit more sense and so i'm
not completed in that journey yet but
i'm
i'm still in it and i'm further along
than i was months ago but uh
yes this first of all the idea of
equivariant versus invariant i think is
you know that took me
a little bit to understand but it's
actually quite simple
um so if you don't mind i'll just say it
out loud for other people that may not
be up to speed yet so equivalent and
invariant the difference is that
for example if you have permutation
equivariance that means if you shuffle
around the inputs then the output that
you get will also be shuffled
whereas in the case of invariant if you
shuffle around the inputs you get the
exact same output
so one sort of
keeps the symmetry by
moving around in the same way
and the other one just ignores the
symmetry and generates the same output
so for convolutional neural networks for
example you have this filter that you
kind of scan across the image
and if you have a cat detector that
lights up when there's a cat well if you
move the cat to a different part of the
image then the part that lights up will
also move
and that's
equivariant
um but the invariant is like pooling
like you said where
maybe you just have something that says
there's a cat or there's not a cat in
this entire image and in that case it
doesn't matter where the cat is you're
gonna get the same output if there is or
is not one so
that took a little bit for me to
appreciate the difference but uh
yeah that recipe you see reflected all
over the place when whenever there's a
symmetry
that can be exploited and of course
the reason you want to exploit these
sorts of symmetries is the architectures
you get
are more parameter efficient basically
so yeah those filters you know are
shared across the image and that's a lot
easier to do than to have to learn
um
a filter for
cat over here and a different filter for
cat over here and so on
yeah exactly
i spoke with joanne bruner
and he was saying oh you know well the
problem with machine learning is there
are all of these curses everywhere and
all of these different um kind of
sources of error and he spoke about
approximation error and statistical
error and optimization error and
he said that um you know with these
different architectures one of the most
important things that we do to to reduce
one of these curses a computational
curse is to um reduce the approximation
class or the hypothesis space so in
machine learning we're trying to find a
function
well we're trying to approximate a
function you know to represent the
actual function
and
if that class is too big we'll be
searching forever so what we could do is
is reduce the size of functions we're
searching through but then that that
introduces approximation error because
even if we find the best function in
that space it might not you know
it might not have enough fidelity to
represent the actual function that that
we want to uh learn but so all of these
different group symmetry equivariant
layers the group means a group of
symmetry transformations and in the case
of a cnn the symmetry is translational
uh symmetry
so what we're basically saying is we now
have a much smaller approximation class
because rather than learn this thing in
every possible position we only learn
the thing prototypically
and then it could be represented in any
position
it's interesting all the different
sort of if you read the theory side of a
lot of these things
to me i like my brain works better by
getting an intuitive understanding of
why something would work and then the
theory kind of helps make connections in
ways that i i wouldn't you know wouldn't
be obvious starting out and it's kind of
interesting to hear the perspective you
just laid out of the function class and
restricting that and making basically an
easier optimization problem maybe
is is kind of the crux of that
but
there's all sorts of other different
approaches theoretically that talk about
the same part of a different part of the
same elephant you know and that's kind
of the the fun part for me of exploring
these more theoretical papers is it just
kind of
makes different parts of your brain
light up and then if you do that over a
long enough time on enough topics i
think that's what helps
researchers you know bring new and
innovative approaches like basically
bronstein the geometric they're bringing
this perspective of these
symmetries i think he has a physics
background and uh then this
these other types of geometries and
stuff
that uh seems to be a fruitful way of
exploring and now they're bringing in
partial differential equations and
and uh
treating them as like
continuous diffusion equations that are
now when you discretize them it's uh
these gnn layers and so it's just a
totally different way of looking at it
that my brain would have never thought
of but it's really enriching to kind of
go through some of these different
approaches
i know really fascinates me how
deep ideas can marshal different domains
of science or you know for example ideas
in physics come coming into machine
learning and when we spoke to bronstein
he he showed us the book by roger
penrose which is the road to reality and
he said if i could sum up this entire
book with one word it would be symmetry
that seems to be the
uh the modus operandi in the world of
physics
yeah i bought that book as a response to
him recommending it and uh man it's a
it's not light reading so still working
on that one
i started to read it there was i think
the first chapter was all about um the
platonic forms
and unfortunately that's as far as i got
but there are so many books it's it's
absolutely insane um how many books that
i need to read yeah at the moment
so um
let's talk a little bit about uh graph
neural networks because this this is
your your area of specialism and um
we were speaking to a guy actually last
week all about cellular automata and
that's
very very similar to graph neural
networks in this sense of message
passing right so in a cellular automata
you kind of like um you're on a
grid uh
on a plane our manifold and that has
this idea that every single node is is
connected to its neighbors
but um you could generalize that to a
graph where the concept of a
neighborhood
doesn't necessarily have to be a gridded
surface anymore but
that's quite similar to message passing
in in the sense that what you do is you
run some code that runs on every single
pixel or in a graph it would be on every
single node and you're passing
information between the nodes because
you're executing a whole bunch of rules
and so you can think of of graph neural
networks as being a generalization of
cnns in that sense that you're just
passing information between the
neighboring pixels
uh so this notion of message passing is
absolutely critical for gnns right
yeah for sure so the connection with uh
cnns as you're saying
the question might be why not just use
cnns well the really
only complication here is that with a
grid of
pixels
the number of neighbors is stable around
a pixel you know you're gonna look at
the immediate neighborhood or maybe a
larger receptive field but
whenever you're moving that thing the
number of neighbors is going to be
consistent and your filter is
essentially going to learn a
a number to multiply each of those pixel
values by and then there's some
aggregation operation like a sum or
whatever
in the case of graphs of course the
number of of neighbors is different for
the various nodes so you can't
imagine a single filter because the next
name the next node might have seven
neighbors whereas the previous had five
so you need a way to handle that
and um
kitfin welding
created the graph convolution network
but that had built up on previous work
that we're basically trying to define
what a convolution operation is on a
graph
and the way they found to do this
essentially was to go into the frequency
domain
and taking the the graph for a transform
basically and
then what they did
was it this world of wavelets which is
so
in the case of fourier transform you
sort of localize the frequency you break
it down into its various frequency
components and then if if you know
anything about audio filtering for
example like a equalizer on a radio or
whatever you basically take the fourier
transform of the
the audio signal which casts it into a
frequency space
and then your little sliders on your
equalizer just amplify or diminish the
content that's in that frequency band
and then when it comes out of the filter
it takes the inverse fourier transform
to get it back to your regular
audio space of just amplitude versus
time and then
now the filter has been applied and
that's your kind of modified version of
the signal so we want to do something
similar here
where we're taking the fourier transform
of the graph
and then
you apply
a multiplication on the different
frequencies that will reduce or amplify
them and then you take the inverse
fourier transform of the graph and there
is your convolution applied because the
convolution theorem says that conv
convolution in one domain is
multiplication in the
other domain which is
fourier domain in this case so
we have this kind of simple recipe
the only problem is that
when you take the fourier transform of a
graph
first of all you have to find all of its
eigenvectors which is an expensive
operation i think it goes as n cubed
where n is the number of nodes and for
billions of graphs or billions of nodes
in a large graph that's obviously quite
a bit and there are approximation
schemes and so on but still that's uh
expensive
and then the the next problem
is that
each
eigenvector
will depend on all of the nodes
and
that means you're inherently non-local
and if you were to
sort of have a perturbation or something
on on a single node it's going to be
impacting all of the other ones and what
we like in
convolutional neural networks on images
for example is that you're kind of
restricting the information to be this
little local neighborhood
so
long story short the way they solved
this problem and this was back to the
graph wavelet's work
so the
a wavelet is not only localized in
frequency like the 48 transform does
because that breaks it down into
frequency components but it also
localizes the
impact in the original spatial domain
so the way they basically did this was
they define the fourier transform
and then they approximated it as a
polynomial in the
adjacency matrix or the laplacian so why
would you do that well if you take a
set of features for your nodes and you
multiply it by the adjacency matrix
that does message passing so if you if
you recall the adjacency matrix is zero
for things that are not connected so
let's say you're looking at the first
row so that's node one there's a one
where
it's connected to all the other nodes so
you have a set of rows that represent
the
the nodes and the set of columns that
also represent the nodes and there's
zeros where they're not connected and
ones where they are when you multiply
the adjacency matrix by the features
what you end up doing is just adding up
the uh the features of all the connected
neighbors and that's message passing
right so
if you just think through the the matrix
multiplication it's like you're going
down
the uh
the zeros and ones and you're adding it
up
when you're multiplying the various
features and this ask
acts like a mask right you're
multiplying by zero all the things that
are not connected and multiplying by one
all the things that are and adding it
all up and that's just a form of message
passing
so
if you multiply by the adjacency matrix
one time
you're getting all the nearest neighbors
if you multiply by the adjacency matrix
squared
you're aggregating the two-hop
neighborhood
so that's all of
that a squared represents all of the
paths between two nodes
so if there's like
you know you go to one neighbor and then
back
then that's one path or you could go to
you know you could imagine many
different paths through the graph
basically to go from one node to another
and the value in the a squared basically
tells you how many paths exist between
two nodes
and that generalizes to the kth power of
the adjacency matrix so if you went to a
to the fifth power then you would have a
number of how many paths of link length
five exist between two nodes
so what they did
was they expressed
an approximation they said okay we're
just going to do a polynomial expansion
to the convolution
using powers of the adjacency matrix
and
obviously it's just like any other
polynomial expansion the more terms the
more accurate it's going to be and you
know they were smart in which
polynomial they use chebyshev
polynomials that have certain properties
that basically make it a good
approximator using a small number of
terms
and they talk about this in the graph
wavelet's paper
but in any case they have this
polynomial expansion and then they say
okay
let's just restrict it to the first term
so we have the
adjacency matrix to the zero with power
which is a constant
plus
adjacency matrix to the first power
and then there's parameters that you
know are multiplying this
and what that does is that localizes the
information to be in a one hop
neighborhood
and that solves the problem of
if i use the full fourier transform i
have non-local information through
throughout the entire graph
which is a bad thing right and also it's
not intuitive to say
this node on the total other side of the
graph is going to have
an influence on my current node that's
in most problems that's not really
relevant what you need is just the
immediate neighborhood
so
by approximating the convolution as a
first order approximation
with the adjacency matrix you've now
limited the uh
the places the information can come from
from each node
and that was kind of the unlocking idea
that allowed graph convolutional
networks because not only have you
localized the information but you've
also made it just this really simple
linear equation where it's just the
adjacency matrix multiplied by the
features and then you pass that through
a non-linearity and that's it so this is
really interesting because this reminds
me a little bit again in in bronstein
and velikovic's work they were talking
about how they could re-derive the
convolution
convolutional neural networks from first
principles using the convolution theorem
and the shift matrix and and
as you know like a convolution on your
network can be represented with with a
um with with a single fine
transformation
and similarly this is the magic of
linear algebra that you can you can
represent this kind of uh local message
passing with with an affair
transformation which is fascinating
um
but
there's
there's a dichotomy isn't there between
going bottom up to represent information
and top down presumably there are some
advantages to
global
information sharing but
so often is the case again with cellular
automata by the way that going bottom up
can give you a surprising degree of
global coherence
and information
so why does it work so well going bottom
up
there's a paper that i read a long time
ago back when i was in the world of
physics
that i
i didn't understand that well
i understood the message of it but i
didn't understand much beyond that and
uh his name is william byalick i'm
probably mispronouncing that
i believe he's a princeton
and it's a paper that's showing
how
most systems and their complicated
behavior can be explained by pairwise
interactions
and there's some things that can't
but the amount of things that can't are
very small and i think that's
i i may be uh misapplying that because
again i did not understand it deeply but
it seems to me like message passing in
these which essentially are pairwise
interactions right it's one node
ascending information to another node
that you can capture quite a lot of
information that models a system with
just that
and there are some cases so there are
blind spots and i'm sure we'll get into
this because this is related to the
bottleneck of genens and the bottleneck
of their expressive power
that uh
for example closed triangles versus open
triangles are hard to distinguish and
that's because that's inherently a three
node operation right it's like
you can't receive a message from this
node to tell you if it's connected to
this node necessarily that it's more
like are all three of these connected
you need to kind of know the state of
all three of those things
and
unfortunately close triangles are
actually really important for a lot of
tasks so you
my background in machine learning is a
lot with fraud detection and you can
imagine that if you have close triangles
that mean to these kind of tightly knit
communities
and that's often what you see with these
coordinated attacks by fraudsters
and if you can't distinguish that then
that's a problem now
it's not to say that gnns can't
tell tightly connected communities from
ones that are not that's not true but
there are certain structures in certain
edge cases where they have a hard time
and that's
powering a lot of the the work along
that direction of this bottleneck and
first of all trying to characterize it
but then also trying to break it and
sort of unlock more expressive power but
there's also quite a bit of uh
sort of
lingering questions around if this is
even that important because on all of
the benchmark data sets we have
these really
these architectures that come out and
have the more expressive power don't
really perform that much better than
what we have with just message passing
with the bottlenecks inside so the
question is well is that because
i i wonder is is there two possibilities
one is that
we just don't need more expressive power
for the realistic task and that these
kind of corner cases of where it fails
are just not prevalent in real life
graphs
that could be one case the other is that
it's not so much a question right now
of bottlenecks of expressive power but
in terms of recipes of training gnns
that you know maybe we need our our
batch norm or whatever it is these kind
of tricks of training and optimization
that are really the things that are
hurting us right now and then we'll run
into the bottleneck question sort of
down the road so yeah i don't know which
of those it is or a third one that i
haven't thought of but well i think it's
related to the bias fairness trade-off i
mean
we've been speaking a lot recently about
why do neural networks use
piecewise linear functions you know for
their approximation class um
all of the equations in physics that
we've derived are non-linear functions
but it's coming back to what we were
saying earlier if you make the
approximation class too big then you've
just got too much stuff to search
through and actually if you have too
much bias in your model as well it can
actually make you worse on average
that's the
that's the paradox of machine learning
isn't it
um
i'm really interested in
so many things that you just said there
one first thought that came to my mind
is again in cellular automata
one thing that they do is is they don't
perform the update synchronously they
start doing it stochastically because
what we've been speaking about in graph
neural networks and the message message
passing is that it happens synchronously
and because neural networks have a fixed
amount of compute and there are certain
structures um you would need to perform
that computation iteratively um several
times presumably in order for you to
recognize certain structures in the in
the graph
if there if there was a ring structure
in the graph if i understand correctly
uh
and i think this is getting to why we
need to have several equivariant layers
per permutation equivalence in the graph
because you would actually need to
effectively perform message passing a
discrete number of times in order to
detect that structure effectively right
the number of
gnn layers you have
let's just speak sort of approximately
there are some architectures that do
things differently but in general one g
n layer is one
stage of message passing
and
if the information you need
is uh five or six steps away then you
need five or six g n layers
if you're just following the kind of
standard approach and that just doesn't
work very well for a number of reasons
the first is that
they call it the over smoothing problem
where
if you
do a stage of message passing you
combine all of the information from your
neighbors
along with the information of yourself
and then apply it through some neural
network or whatever the function is and
this comes up with a new representation
of that node
and then if you repeat this operation
you gather the neighbors you take your
current representation so it's like a
this continuous update where each time
you do message passing you're
pulling in all the information and then
updating your own representation and you
can imagine that if you do that over and
over and over again that all the nodes
start taking on a very similar
representation because they're
constantly pulling things in and then
eventually they're pulling in things
from far away and you're just making
this big homogenous blob and that's the
over smoothing problem so you have that
to contend with the other is what they
call the over squashing problem which is
that
even if you don't over smooth you're
gathering a lot of information
an exponentially increasing amount of
information because when your first set
of message passing you just have your
nearest neighbors and but the second and
let's say you have a d of them you know
for degree d
and uh
the
next set of message passing
your the first one kind of updates
everything and you each node has its
neighbor represented but then the second
set you have your neighbors neighbors
also represented so that's kind of d
squared
and then if you do it a third time it's
d to the third power so you have this
exponentially increasing amount of
information
coming that you're supposed to be
representing with these kind of fixed
size vectors
and um that's the oversquashing problem
it's also seen kind of in recurrent
neural networks right that if you have
your rnn and you're going over a very
long sequence length you're still you're
now trying to cram in a lot of
information from this long sequence into
this fixed size vector and eventually
you could imagine running out of
capacity because
even from an information theoretic point
of view and the paper on over squashing
does a really nice job of this that
you know you let's say you have a vector
with uh
eight 32-bit floats
well you know precisely how many
configurations that could possibly
differentiate right because each bit
can tell you um whether it's one
configuration versus not and you know
how many bits are in this vector so if
you have more configurations than that
you can't possibly
differentiate among them with a vector
of that size
and the number of possible
configurations
explodes if your receptive field is
increasing exponentially so you have to
deal with that problem
one of the ways they've been
dealing with that is
this kind of graph rewiring
work which is there's nothing to say
that the graph you're given in your data
is the right graph for doing message
passing
it's the most natural one but you could
also imagine
that
in these
like like you're talking about these
kind of molecular
structures where you might have these
aromatic rings that require these kind
of six hops away before you even know
your inner ring well maybe the
computation
graph should be different than
the one of molecules connected by edges
or atoms connected by edges to build
these molecules
and this graph rewiring
and bronstein's work of like the reachy
curvature and so on is about finding
a process for updating these edges or
creating edges where they didn't
previously exist and removing edges that
do exist because there are certain edges
that cause this over squashing problem
because they will connect a node to a
different disparate connect of densely
connected things and if you could just
remove that one edge you would eliminate
a lot of information that needed to be
maintained in these vectors
and so that work is about sort of
finding those edges that you can
selectively remove to
optimally reduce this over squashing
problem so there's lots of different
approaches out there but you're exactly
right
there's a
it's not trivial to just make gnns
deeper because of this exponential
increase in the receptive field and you
know cnns do not have that problem right
yeah
this is absolutely fascinating um
i'm sorry to bring it up again but it it
it really makes me think of um cellular
automata ex because we we interviewed a
guy called danielle gratarola and um he
extended cellular automata to graphs
and there's you might have seen there's
a blog post about um it's called
morphogenesis
so you can
essentially have
the morphogenesis it was first done on a
cnn and then he did it with a graph so
um
instead of a normal cellular automator
of discrete rules you have a continuous
version and you train a cnn and you
train it to reconstruct an image so you
can kind of you can kind of um damage
part of it or destroy part of it and
then it will just as an emergent
property the image will recreate itself
and actually what's happening there is
in a graph neural network you have a
fixed number of message passing updates
but in a cellular automator it just it
continuously happens so and and
and the way that these guys are training
the the model was to try and make it
converge and not degenerate because you
were just saying there's this dichotomy
between on the one hand the information
might squash and on the other hand it
might diverge and it might be possible
if you imagine this is a continuous
process to make it um converge in into a
good place but what's happening with
graph neural networks as you say is is
you're you're actually having a discrete
number a fixed number of message passing
increments and the topology of the under
underlying graph uh strongly determines
where that goes
yeah that actually makes an interesting
connection back to something we briefly
alluded to with bronstein's work on this
uh
partial differential equations
and
so
you know the heat equation if you
remember that from college physics or
whatever it's basically the uh laplacian
operator which is the kind of double
derivative thing
um on
so it's basically a smoothness thing
that you know heat dissipates and it
does it isotropically through the
material so hot spots
will
take their ambient heat and send it to
the neighbors and it sort of diffuses
down to this
smooth thing and
um bronstein's
work and
i'm not remembering the first author so
i apologize for that but i know it's
coming from his his world
are
thinking about
you know gnns as a sort of diffusion
process right where right now
it's isotropic in that it doesn't matter
which neighbor it comes from they're
treated equally but that may not be the
right thing to do
and
there may be expressive power
um things that you can gain by breaking
that requirement
but um in any case you were talking
about how these are kind of discrete
well they've
talked about a world where it's not
discrete it's continuous so what would a
continuous gnn layer look like or
maybe you don't say layer in that case
but a continuous
message passing
framework look like
and um
i didn't you know i somewhat understand
the way they framed that but i didn't
quite make the connection of how they
would
manifest this into a real-life
architecture until quite recently
emanuel rossi from twitter and also has
connections from bronstein released this
paper on uh
it's called something like the
unreasonable effectiveness of feature
propagation or something like that
and basically what they did was they
took this approach of having this
diffusion equation that represented
information uh on the graph and the
question is what if a lot of our feature
information
is deleted you know or if you think
about a twitter graph you have let's say
the age and gender and so on of some of
your users but a lot of users just don't
give it to you so you have this missing
information missing features on your
nodes
well they they treat it as well let's do
a diffusion equation this this partial
differential equation and my boundary
conditions will be my observations so
for the nodes where i have
the age and gender that's the considered
a boundary condition
and for the ones that i don't have an
observation that's just a thing i need
to make an inference about and i need to
find
the solution to my differential equation
such that it first of all matches this
update kind of diffusion equation but
also matches my boundary conditions
and then you know you see that
there is a closed form solution to this
differential equation but it's expensive
to calculate of course so then they say
okay well what if we uh
basically initialize things and then
play this
update equation forward to get a new
state and basically do this
euler approximation where you know i've
discretized
my steps and i'm just going to update
have a new representation and keep
feeding it through this differential
equation until i meet a steady state and
that's my approximate solution well that
is basically gnns and that is message
passing
so it's a
a way to think about
what these things are and
applying
thinking about it from the perspective
of a continuous thing that's now been
had this discrete process put on top and
playing the tape forward until
convergence
is essentially the formula that that
solves this thing given these boundary
conditions so i thought that was a nice
example of where the rubber meets the
road of okay here's this cool way of
thinking about it but how do you turn it
into something in practice that works
and it turns out it works very very well
so it is a really cool way of thinking
about it and um we we've been speaking
recently ever since we spoke to randall
balestrio from meta it completely
transformed how i think about neural
networks and you know he's without going
into too much detail he's got this
spline theory of neural networks which
talks about how all of the neurons are
these basis functions which are released
they're basically hyperplanes and in an
input sensitive way the mlps chop up the
the ambient space up into these
polyhedra
um so it's a bit like a locality
sensitive hashing table and then all of
the neural network architecture so all
of you know the geometric deep learning
blueprint in a variety of different ways
they actually perform information
diffusion just as you were describing so
what they basically do is is they um
i mean the idealized version would be a
cellular automata but actually it
happens with discrete
um steps of information diffusion so
even a cnn or a gnn they all work the
same way they basically take the
information and they defuse it so that
the information falls into those
different polyhedra in the ambient space
so that the mlp back end will learn to
recognize information in different
places
yeah and i think
that somewhat drives with
the recognition so we started by talking
about the bottleneck of expressive power
but um
what we have actually seen
in a bunch of results is that simple
things work really well
and so there was this paper called
correct and smooth that basically
it was somewhat uh surprising at the
time because this very simple recipe
that they came out with beat all of the
gnns or many of the gnns on
most of the benchmarks and the recipe
was simply something like
fit a model
like a tree based model xgboost or
whatever
and
that has nothing to do with the graph
it's just maps features to prediction
and then build your graph
and
apply
basically label propagation
but
the thing you're trying to propagate are
the errors or the residuals between the
ground truth answer and the predictions
and that basically you know
assigns an expected error to each of the
nodes
and then
adjust your
baseline xg boost score by that error
amount
and then apply label propagation on top
of that and
that recipe of just doing smoothing
where you're finding expected errors so
that the intuition here is that if one
node has a high error
then its connected neighbor will likely
also have a high error
that's the first set and then the other
is that the labels should vary smoothly
across the graph
and that worked very very well and as
someone from industry who's worked on
some graph problems i can tell you label
propagation is very hard to beat it's
simple and it's uh it's elegant and it's
very similar to what we were just
talking about of this idea of
playing the tape forward in a
differential equation and the
the feature propagation work that came
out of rosi's paper
is almost identical to label propagation
the only difference is that the thing
you're propagating is the vector of
features and not the label
and um
that by the way worked really well too
so it seems like we're coming from this
uh a different perspective on the
problem where the thing that the graph
is giving you that's really helpful for
these tasks and where you're getting
your performance benefit is this
smoothing over the local graph
neighborhood and like these graph
convolutional networks for example where
we
to bring this
full circle back home
these
low order approximations
using um small powers on the adjacency
matrix
well these turn out to be low pass
filters meaning that it's
um doing low frequency information
which by definition is things that vary
um slowly across the graph so from node
basically it means that there's
smoothing being done
and
that works really well and it seems to
be that
it may
simply combining local information and
making it smooth is where you get almost
all of your benefit from these
graph-based methods yeah and it the
expressive power may be uh not that
important yeah i'm just i've got a
visual in my mind it i hadn't i hadn't
heard about it uh this way before so
this is fascinating you're saying you
know you change the power on the
adjacency matrix and it's almost a
little bit like you know with the radial
basis function you have you have like
this kind of smoothing effect and what
you're basically doing is you're saying
how much i want to diffuse and smooth
the information over my neighborhood as
a function of how many um steps in
respect to
degrees the reason that's interesting is
i i actually thought there must have
been a computational reason for this but
it's not it's more of a bottom-up versus
top-down reason because as we were
saying at the beginning it can be
harmful to have too much global
information it's much better to diffuse
the information bottom bottom up because
this brings me naturally to the question
of transformers now
in transformers it is explicitly a
quadratic term and you achieve the
permutation in variance by looking at
all of the k
tuples of the items in the set where k
equals two in the case of self-attention
so you can think of transformers as
being a graph learning problem so how
would you contrast transformers with
let's say a gcm
yeah so there's basically
there has been work that make this
connection explicit but um essentially
you can think of a transformer as a
fully connected graph
and
if every node is connected to every
other node and you do message passing
that is this
you know k squared
number of interactions and they of
course have this formal
like update mechanism of
keys and queries and so on
but
at a high level
gnns are trying to be
more
sparse in what is considering and if you
have the computational power
to consider the interactions of
everything with everything else i don't
think we're going to beat that so
transformers are are going to win
probably
um
unless there's something
you know
the graph encodes relationships and um
inductive priors if you will about it
says something about how this thing is
connected to another thing and the
degree to which that is useful
information is the degree to which the
graph is going to help you
at the end of the day right
and you could imagine
um
there are papers let's see i think it
was in the over
the over squashing
paper where basically they had these
gnns
that they had stacked together and then
their way of showing that there was
this inefficiency in transmitting
information from far away was for the
last g n they basically made a fully
connected adjacency matrix which kind of
approximates the transformer of
everything's going to be able to talk to
everything else
and if
all of the information you needed was
already there then doing that wouldn't
help at all but it turned out to help in
many cases
so that sort of tells you something
about how the message passing operation
when the message that you need is far
away is not being
transmitted efficiently
so
there might be interesting
[Music]
lessons we can learn from transformers
that will make better gnn architectures
but
i i think really the the crux of the
matter
the the part i'm most optimistic about
are these kind of rewiring techniques i
think because
it's going to be hard to
try to increase your receptive field
really large to get a message from far
away when at the end of the day the
actual problem from my perspective is
that
you're using the wrong edges like
the edge you want to encode in your
problem is i need information from this
thing to make a prediction about this
thing
and if you're using edges that directly
fall out of your
perception of the data like chemical
bonds
well okay that's that's one way to
represent a relationship but the fact
that these things you know as an
alternative in the case of molecules
maybe instead of representing nodes as
atoms you represent nodes as more
complicated things maybe you have a node
for each aromatic ring for example and
then you've solved this problem of
needing
information from six hops away because
you're just explicitly saying i know
that aromatic rings are important so
therefore i'm going to make that a sort
of
atomic thing in my uh information that
i'm representing so
there are ways around this that
don't involve throwing a bunch of g n
layers at it just to try to get the
message
from message passing yeah a lot of this
comes into the human engineering thing
though right so you could create
inductive prize and you could say i i
think i think this thing's very
important and you could argue as some
folks do that it's almost like a
platonic you know like symmetries
translation symmetry i mean that's a
platonic ideal right that can't just be
something that we've plucked out of thin
air it must be something really
important but there's always a bit of a
spectrum of of how important something
isn't and isn't but i wanted to bring
this full circle a little bit so and
first of all folks i recommend you check
out um zach's recent interview that he
did with with the folks from that paper
equivalent subgraph aggregation networks
and um you know as i understand that the
main idea behind that paper was the way
that this message passing works in
neural networks actually fails in
certain cases so there are certain
functions that fails to represent so
they came up with this idea of why don't
we create a policy to essentially
decompose
a graph into lots of other graphs and
then we could represent them with and
that policy could be i don't know get me
all the minimum spanning trees of this
graph that would be a dumb thing to do
because i think they said there's
exponentially many of them but something
like that and and then and then you you
stack all of those adjacency matrices
and and then you work on that so
they said that there's um an interesting
analogy between you know there's this
thing called the weiss fella lemon
isomorphism test and they said there was
an analogy between that and message
passing so anything that the um
you know the wl test fails on message
passing would fail on so could you give
us a bit of flavor on that
yeah there's a paper from yuri
leskovitch's group on exploring the
express the power of gnns and they make
this explicit connection to the 1wl so
basically the the theorem that they show
is that anything that the 1wl test fails
on
to
you know fails to discriminate between
two graphs is whether they're the same
or not or isomorphic is the more precise
term
uh then gnns will fail on that same
thing and it speak so let's first maybe
describe the 1wl algorithm it's it's
basically message passing so the idea is
that you have two graphs and you don't
know whether they're the same or not
because it's actually not obvious by
looking at them you can rearrange the
nodes and the way you draw them and two
things that look very different can
actually be identical graphs the
algorithm goes assign everything the
same label to start off or they call it
a color and you give everything let's
say a zero
and then for each node
you gather
all of the labels of its connected
neighbors and you create a multi-set so
what's the difference between a
multi-set and a set is that the same
element can occur more than once
so let's let's say you have a node of
degree three meaning it has three
neighbors then
when you collected its information the
multiset would be three zeros because
everything has the same
starting out
and then you
also include the label information of
the node itself so you would have a zero
and then its neighborhood would be zero
zero zero
and then you would hash that
and create a unique value for every
unique set of
neighborhood
label sets
and let's say we call that one okay so
everything that had degree three
in that first step would now have a
label of one
and then
you do that for all the other nodes so
basically what you're doing is you're
finding all of the unique local
neighborhoods and then assigning that a
new label
and now you have that thing
then you run this again
and again and again so you end up
getting this table that maps all of
these unique structures to colors or
labels or whatever
and you run this until it's converged
and if at the end
and by converged it means that
all of the nodes that share
a label
in iteration k also share a label in
iteration k plus 1. so the actual label
values will change but all of the nodes
that have the same color will have the
same color again when you do it so
that's called convergence and then if
you compare the two graphs those that
have basically the same distribution of
labels are isomorphic they're the same
and that's that's the way um we sort of
test whether these two graphs are the
same and it turns out that there are
certain cases
where for example
let's say you have uh six nodes
one of them is in a ring
and
you can imagine different geometries
and i you'd probably have to flash some
on the screen that are like these
degenerate cases where basically they
are very different graphs you can tell
that by looking at them but if you run
this one wl test they say they are the
same
and it's known that that's the case so
the strongest claim you can make
is that
if two graphs fail the one wl test
they're not isomorphic
but if two graphs pass the 1wl test you
still don't know whether they're
isomorphic or not so it's only the
failure case that gives you a definitive
answer
and
gcn or gnns are basically doing the same
thing right they're gathering the
information but instead of passing it
through a hash function to generate the
next label they pass it through a neural
network
so the connection here is that basically
the gnns are a differentiable version of
the 1wl test
and
the
one thing that they do which is the
source of their bottleneck
is that they aggregate
that multi-set so instead of having zero
zero zero
or
um some list of labels they apply some
aggregation scheme
and
they sum them they average them whatever
it is they do but they combine this
neighborhood of information
with some aggregation which is what
gives them their permutation and
variance by the way this aggregation
step but uh
but that aggregation of collapsing this
multiset into a single representation is
the source of where they lose their
ability to distinguish beyond what the
1wl can do so there are certain cases
where you can imagine
i'm connected let's say we're using the
average aggregation function
let's say i'm connected to two red and
two blue
well if i average that then i'm gonna
have half red and half blue
now let's say i have four red and four
blue
i'm going to get the same answer from
the gcn because it's at the end of the
day just going to average the proportion
of these labels
the 1wl test would pass in that case
because it would know that i have 2
versus 4. so what the paper says
is that the
only way you can
achieve the upper bound of this one wl
test is if you use a
injective
aggregation function so it basically
means that if you have a unique set of
inputs you generate a unique output and
that the sum aggregator is the best we
have
and um
that way you can imagine if you one hot
encode all of your labels and you sum
them you get a count of how many red and
how many blue and then you can always
sort of recreate
the
same thing as what the hash function
would do because you're getting a count
of unique
labels assuming your vector is big
enough to one hot encode all the
possible labels so that that's the way
they make the connection with the 1wl
test is they basically say we're going
to fail in the same places because given
the same inputs and we can never have
better inputs than one wl because again
you're just gathering the neighbors
we're going to fail in the same places
we'll also fail in more places if our
aggregation function is not injective
so if we restrict it to these certain
classes then we can be as powerful as
the 1wl test and then they develop this
architecture called graph isomorphism
networks that basically leverages these
ideas and comes up with a final kind of
update solution that is guaranteed
to uh match the 1wl power
that's absolutely fascinating i was
trying to understand a little bit about
this aggregation because when we had
thomas luxon the other day we spoke
about in all of the architectures
there's this notion of permuting and
then aggregating
and he thought that the secret was in
the aggregation more than the permuting
but um in a typical you know we said
there's the layers of the sandwich and
there's the equivalent layers and
there's the invariant layers the
equivariant layers don't aggregate or do
they
the so the equivariant layers are
basically the um
the ones that are going to give you
an output for every node
and um
so
it's a little bit a g n basically
stacks
the equivalent and invariant together so
the um invariant part comes in and
collapsing
the
neighbors
of a node into a single representation
so
let's just
be explicit because it's simpler let's
say we're using the sum aggregator
and you're just adding up the uh the
features of all the nodes
so then it doesn't matter whether you
have three neighbors or ten neighbors
you're going to get the same size output
right
if you add three vectors or 10 vectors
also the order doesn't matter so if you
add vector 1 2 3 or 3 2 1 the sum
operation
is uh
the order doesn't matter
so
in that sense
that's invariant
but if you apply that recipe to every
node independently
where you say for node one gather your
neighbors and do that operation
node five gather your neighbors do that
operation
the fact that you're applying the same
recipe to every node independently is
what gives you your equivariance
because
if you shuffle the nodes
and apply that recipe again
the uh the output you get you know now
you'll get the output from node five
with um
where you said was node one because
you've swapped those things
but uh it's not going to change the
output you get for that particular node
it's just going to change the ordering
and that's because you've shuffled them
so that's the equivariance that comes in
that basically for gnns applying the
same neural network the same weight
shared neural network to each node
independently gives you your
equivariance and then
applying an aggregation to the
neighborhood is your invariance and you
kind of stack that together to get both
amazing amazing well um
zach you've been creating a course i
mean i know you've been really busy
because you stopped putting out videos
on your channel about six months ago
because you've been busy putting all of
this course content together i had a
quick look at the curriculum and i mean
i'm going to be signing up to this
course myself i'm really excited about
it but can you just tell folks um what's
the structure of the course how can they
sign up and when you're running it
sure um
it's kind of in two components one is
theory and one is hands-on so the theory
covers a lot of what we were just
talking about but uh the focus is not on
being
super exhaustive and being very long
it's instead focused on kind of finding
the key ideas that underlie a lot of the
seminal works
and communicating them efficiently and
like let's get you there quickly and uh
and move on but you know it's not going
to basically prepare you for
writing your dissertation probably but
it's going to unlock the kind of basic
ideas that you need to know to
understand some of these papers and read
them and get the
key ideas so it goes through the graph
fourier transforms and and convolution
and so on and basically builds up the
math that you need to understand graph
convolutional networks and the
bottlenecks and so on
the hands-on piece
is a little bit different because i'm
running it in cohorts of students so the
theory part you can kind of take
whenever you want
the
hands-on piece
enrollments only open for a couple weeks
and then we close it down and run the
session and there's basically three
segments where you are building gnns
through guided exercises and there's
videos that walk you through solutions
and so on and there's a discord
community where you can ask questions
and that's why i wanted to be cohort
based so that people can kind of work
through it together code review and so
on but the three main things we cover
there are
the exam the three major uh examples of
where gnns are applied which is like a
node classification link prediction and
then graph classification and those are
kind of the three areas
where gnns are applied today
so we do that right now
enrollment is open but it closes april
1st is when we're getting started
and then that'll run for six weeks and
probably open up enrollment again
sometime after that in the summer but
that's kind of where it stands right now
amazing well um i think it's so
important to have a sense of community
and buzz i mean we just recently started
our discord community i know you've got
one for your channel as well zach and
folks should should sign up to that but
um it keeps you accountable doesn't it
when when you're with a cohort i mean i
remember when i went to university just
that sense of
collegial um atmosphere and and doing it
being in it with other people i think
that makes all the difference yeah for
me the
deadlines are really uh useful you know
it's like i don't like them and add
stress to my life but if i don't have
any kind of deadlines things you know
everybody's so busy and other things
come up so i wanted to do it as a cohort
and like have a start and a finish and
hopefully that encourages people to
to finish the actual work because that's
really what it takes to learn something
exactly was it douglas adams who said
deadlines make a wishing sound when they
fly past
which is great
well um zach i really appreciate you
coming on and by the way if folks would
like another dose of zack i was
listening back to this recently and as
that came on and we had a discussion on
the social dilemma film the the first of
three but it was by far the best of the
three and um i was listening to it
recently zach and your your
contributions on that were absolutely
amazing so i definitely recommend folks
go back into the catalogue and listen to
that one
oh interesting i'd like to revisit it
myself it's been a long time i hadn't
thought about that movie in a while so
cool yeah i know it was such an
interesting discussion because i was
really inspired by another podcast
called the moral maze and i always
wanted to model our channel on that a
little bit and it's very kind of like
academic and intellectual and going deep
into things and and that was a great
example of you know one of my original
visions for mlst so that was great
well speaking of i've
really enjoyed watching what your
channel has become and the the cool
things you guys are doing and where
you're pushing it it's been
just a pleasure to watch so
congratulations
please keep it up
awesome zach thank you so much for
coming on and we'll certainly have you
back on soon i really appreciate it
great thanks tim
i hope you enjoyed the show folks if you
like content like this remember to hit
the like and subscribe button
and uh consider rating our podcast on
apple podcasts also we're looking for
sponsors as well so if you're interested
reach out to me and we will see you on
the next one